the british kickboxing council
an organization i had not previously
been aware of tweeted
uh in the end of march today we
celebrate trans day of visibility as our
trans inclusion and kickboxing project
continues
access to sport they say is a
fundamental human right supported by the
olympic charter
please read emily's story and check out
mermaid's uk
brand new active about inclusion website
below so for those of you who don't know
mermaids uk
is an ideological organization that is
doing tremendous amount of harm and of
course they're claiming to be about the
new civil rights fight for you know
trans
awareness and inclusion but um it's
really quite i'm just going to use the
word again diabolical
actually um but when you when you go
into this site what you find is that the
british kickboxing council is proud that
now they're going to let
trans women um compete against women
so i said in response to that quote
tweeting for those of you who
are unfamiliar blissfully unaware of
twitter what i said was
this week in progress men can kick women
for fun and if you object
you're the problem to which someone uh
who said who is on twitter as a quote
unquote enlightened scientist
says responds to me anyone who has been
involved in martial arts knows men and
women and boys and girls frequently
sparring together and learning about
inclusion respect and fairness are
fundamental to this principle
i'm not sure what the problem is here
really probably we can just leave it
there but
anyone who invokes the
cool fact that at this point in history
certainly girls and boys
but let's put that aside for the moment
but that men and women can get together
and engage in sport together including
martial arts
on a friendly basis conflating that
with competition which pretends that men
and women
are the same and that all you have to do
to be for to turn
from one and to the other is to declare
that you have
is so misunderstanding of reality and
frankly so misogynistic and dangerous to
women who would compete
that not being you know being able to
finish a tweet with i'm not sure what
the problem is here well
really if you can't see what the problem
with encouraging men who've declared
themselves women to compete in
kickboxing against
women is i'm not sure how to help you
like wha what what do you say to him
yeah well
as you're talking i'm i'm seeing the
picture
even more clearly terrific here's what i
see
you've got two sides of this argument
one of them says trans rights
right it sees only that as an objective
and who could object
trans rights trans rights are good i
would agree trans rights are good
there's the other side
that recognizes that there's a tension
between something which is you would
like
to give trans people as much leeway to
live in a way that feels authentic and
right to them as you can
but that if you just simply grant them
every right as if they were born into
the other sex
that you start infringing on things like
the protections of women and so
one side is engaged in a discussion of
how do we draw this
line so that the ideal balance is
discovered
right so that we do protect trans people
and we do protect
women and we do so simultaneously right
and the other side only wants to talk
about one side of a trade-off now in my
opinion
the side that wants to talk about one
side of a trade-off
is not offering anything it is a act of
purest
advocacy and we have an obligation not
to listen in some sense it's not
even a complex systems level problem
it's just a systems level problem
well and i i i agree
um but also there are places in this
discussion about trans rights
uh where you know all all reasonable
people i've ever met
are interested in accommodating people
such that they can feel respected
regarding the choices they are making so
long
as no impinging is done on pre-existing
rights of other people
and so especially when what is required
is
i declare myself x but actually you know
we all know that i'm not but i declare
myself
x um that
at that point i'm not i am not
interested
actually in giving up any of the
hard-won rights of women
or children or homosexuals or
you know to sort of go slightly smaller
with each group in terms of the
the number of humans um who are
represented in each group
or female competitive athletes right and
so you know
sport is a human right i don't know
where that came from but like
imagine for a moment that you believe
that to be true
sport is a human right which again i
think is an absurd
proclamation but even if you think
that's true that is not the same thing
as saying
therefore anyone can compete against
anyone else
if we want if we want to do that and
acknowledge that actually we are no
longer
interested in seeing women win at sport
or engage in team play
or you know be able to be competitive in
in informal sport
then we make everything unisex and we
watch
as men win yep that's it right and the
trans women won't win either against the
men but they will
will win against the women and sure
there are always going to be a couple of
exceptions
and that does not disprove the rule
because populations
and individuals are different and at a
population level
men are going to be stronger and faster
and fiercer in all of this than women
and therefore the elite among them will
be as well yeah
and in fact the tale of the distribution
is what the competition
ends up being about exactly and that you
know that is why this
this response from this um whatever
adjective you use for himself this
scientist
is insane you're talking about the tales
of the distribution
encouraging men and women to spar with
one another as they're both learning
to figure out you know maybe some of the
moves that men and women do that are
different
i don't kickbox i i don't do martial
arts i don't know what they would be but
that could be informative that could be
interesting it's not the same as
competition you're not talking about the
tailslide distribution
right so i guess another way to look at
it
is the accusation
that is supposed to limit you know
you're not supposed to have permission
to discuss
the difficulty of trying to protect
trans rights in the context of
pre-existing rights so we don't have
that permission yet so
we get stigmatized and the stigma is
one of bigotry now how can it be bigotry
if the description of the position that
you hold is
yup i am open to granting any right to
somebody to live as they want to live
up until the point that it starts
infringing on other people's rights
that sounds like a completely
non-arbitrary place it does not sound
like anybody trying to deny somebody
something
right it sounds like trying to preserve
something and so
you know the solution here is that we
actually have to stare down the
accusation
yeah this has zero to do with bigotry
this is not about wanting
anything ill for trans people or not
favoring living authentic lives i'm
gonna go further i think
too often it has a lot to do with
misogyny actually not only does it have
nothing to do with bigotry
um but the people who are claiming that
those of us who are trying to defend
women's spaces and
and you know all the rest of it who
those people who are saying your bigots
very often what they're engaging is
misogyny is misogyny and
sometimes it's even conscious well so i
i think a good way to ask the question
is given these two positions where are
the bigots
right where are the bigots and in fact
this has been a theme of recent history
because of course
that was the thing that made the the
evergreen story and all of the crt stuff
so difficult for the so-called
mainstream
press to deal with was that the bigots
were on a side it wasn't used to them
being on
and so it decided to pretend they
weren't there or that they were on the
other side and that of course
confused everything but which side of
the big it's on i think is a fair
question and
when your position is non-arbitrary and
is based on
uh preserving pre-existing rights rights
that were hard-won
frankly um that's obviously not
motivated by bigotry
you know you used to say a lot uh
something about
the thing in the package is not the
wrapping paper so what's the exact
the label on the box does not match the
contents yeah and so
you know this is something i used to
joke when i was teaching animal behavior
for all those many years
um that uh you know wouldn't it be
easier if the squirrels or the
the butterflies or the monkeys could
talk to us and then we could just ask
them
and you know if you've ever thought
about cultural anthropology and
ethnography and what it takes to
actually figure out what is true of
human behavior
or if you've just ever been a human
really you know
that we prevaricate all the time we lie
all the time and so it's actually much
easier
um if you can as we've also said turn
down the volume
and watch what is actually happening and
then if you can map
if it is an organism that actually
communicates map the conversation onto
it or map the explanation of what's
going on onto it
if it matches cool very often it won't
and then you have something to explain
and so you know it's actually easier to
do animal behavior than it is to do
human behavior
because they're very much the animals
that you're watching are very much less
likely to lie to you you have to learn
some different skills and you have to
learn different kinds of patients and
all of this but
at least they're not trying to convince
you in exactly the mode of communication
that you
have as your most fundamental mode and
so
this thing that people are doing where
they're like all i have to do is slap a
label on the thing
and everyone seems confused they said he
was a racist
he must be a racist they said she was a
transphobic must be a transphobe
like you know it's literally costs
nothing to say that about someone
right there's there's just there's
there's no fact checking
that is even expected behind name
calling it's a simple epithet
right and in fact some of these things
are
it just simply takes the form of
a description of a moral
failing right turf right
turf is leveled as as if it is a
dire failure of character and in fact it
doesn't even
superficially add up to a description of
what it's
it's talking about right
trans-exclusionary
radical feminist a traditional minded
person
is not a radical you know so the basic
point is
it is like saying i you know
it's jacuzz with a kind of empty place
holder
and for some reason people continually
fall for it
[Music]